nous sommes ici à moins de 10 kilomètres
de l'un des fronts principaux dans la
région de donetsk à ce front se trouve
dans la direction disions de violents
combats ont lieu en ce moment
l'artillerie et craignent n est en train
de pilonner des positions
cette position où nous trouvons est tenu
par la défense territoriale c'est à dire
les volontaires qui ont rejoint les
rangs de l'armée ukrainienne
nous ne voulons pas rester assis devant
la tchèque paint nous voulons nous
battre sur le front le commandant peut
vous appeler dans la nuit vous dire que
les russes planifie n'attaque de chars
vous donner l'ordre à votre bataillon de
défendre sa section sur la ligne de
front et vos soldats vont se battre
contre des chars ce n'est pas une blague
c'est un dur combat
les combats ne concerne pas que les
volontaires d'ukrainiens ce soldat est
un citoyen russe
il n'a pas hésité une seconde avant de
prendre les armes pour affronter les
soldats de son propre pays aujourd'hui
il n'a qu'une idée en tête
combattre combattre ceux qui sont sans
honneur qu'il soit de votre famille ou
pas cela n'a pas d'importance la russie
représente le mal à l'échelle planétaire
s'il ya conflit quelque part vous y
trouverez la main du kremlin j'en suis à
99 à 100% sur
une hausse de
18,9 d'autres profitent de leur
expérience dans la vie civile pour la
mettre aujourd'hui au service de l'art
cause c'est le cas de chars tard qui
signifie mineurs pas rare qu'ils ont mis
à brûler par mois passant je travaillais
dans les mines il y a eu des explosions
et un gars est mort à deux mètres de moi
donc je suis calme quand je vois la mort
je ne peux pas dire qu'à un moment j'ai
eu peur mokambo à mener
boivin nous y allons jouer chez retard a
fui le dombass après que les
séparatistes et pris le contrôle de
certaines parties de dounia et lawrence
qu en 2014 il retrouve maintenant sa
région plus déterminé que jamais
je sais ce que les tchétchènes ont fait
nos civils et à nos soldats les
atrocités qu'ils ont commises dans nos
villes maintenant je serais heureux de
les voir et de me battre en face à face
avec mon fusil malgré la différence de
leurs parcours respectifs ces
volontaires de la défense territoriale
sont unis par une même cause défendre
leur patrie avec toutes leurs forces et
par tous les moyens ils n'en sont qu'à
leur troisième mois de combats mais leur
manque d'expérience pourra probablement
être compensée en partie par les armes
plus performantes qui arrivent ici et
qui commence à faire la différence sur
beaucoup de fronts